[Music]
hello welcome to
rci fighting kobe 19 special program
today our guest is the minister of
diversity
and the inclusion and youth badish suga
hi mr sugar how are you doing how are
you hi nandi how are you
i'm good i'm well how are you good
awesome okay my question start
from the outbreak of the kobe 19
pandemic
the insults hatred harassment
instant against the asian community have
sharply increased chinese asian people
around canada have been insulted
beaten what's your reaction to this
i will tell you that
our government under the leadership of
justin trudeau we
condemn racism discrimination xenophobia
hate um we know that these
these acts of violence these acts of
hatred have no space in canada
um for me it's been really disheartening
to see how some people across the
country
because of where they come from have
been treated
and i've been really speaking with
communities across the country including
asian canadian communities and chinese
canadian communities
and some of these individuals who have
been targeted
have actually been in canada for
generations um
and because of the way they look or the
color their skin
or the language they choose to speak
people
around them are feeling that it's okay
uh
to be violent towards them and it's not
okay it's never okay
many canadians expressed their
disappointment
and genuine disbelief that
this level of racism happens or exists
in canada do you
think we have systemic problem of racism
in the society i think as canadians we
pride ourselves
for being um a country of diversity
where diversity is our strength i think
we pride ourselves on being
multicultural
and inclusive i believe what we're
noticing
is that we have work to do and that we
can do more
and build better and i think it's
important that
when we do see these acts of racism and
hatred and violence
that we speak up so yes i i do commend
and thank
the many organizations and people who
work very hard to have an inclusive
canada to create
inclusive diverse spaces but i
also do call out on the people who are
not necessarily doing their part
to also step up and to really think
about the kind of country we want
i want a truly inclusive canada where
every individual
can realize their potential and feel
safe in their communities
and feel safe wherever they are so we
have work to do
is what's clear so you think
is systemic or not
for sure i think if you look at the
history of our country and if you look
at
everyone has immigrated to canada um
less you are indigenous and even the
relationship with indigenous peoples is
one that our government has been
committed to strengthening so that we
have a true nation-to-nation
relationship
but there has been issues within our
systems and there remains
issues within our systems and those are
some of the changes and transformations
we're trying to make and that's why our
government brought forward the
anti-racism secretariat
it has been set up not only as a
resource for canadians
but also for a resource for government
departments so that we're actually
looking at
our hiring practices are we having
people of diverse backgrounds
being able to advance within the public
service and how do we ensure when it
comes to appointments
that our decision making tables and
appointments that we're making better
reflect
our country's diversity and i think that
is what we've not always focused on but
our government since 2015 has been
focused on ensuring
that not only gender be represented but
that we do the gba
plus so that the plus is where my focus
lies that we actually apply these lenses
to not only our appointment process but
to our budgets to all the work that we
do
because it's instrumental we be more
aware of the decisions we're making
and we're also measuring outcomes so
it's important that we collect
data and that we actually look at what
we're um what the outcomes are
and i think what we're seeing with kobit
19 and this pandemic
is that across the country we don't have
a national data set
and even though our government has
brought back the long-form senses
we still have work to do when it comes
to
collecting disaggregated data based on
race or socioeconomic status
and region and the list goes on but
because our government has worked with
provinces and territories to set up the
immunity
task force this is a step that i believe
will help us have
a greater dialogue as to the importance
of all levels of government
working together better together in the
best interest of all canadians
they're talking about to do something to
fix it
as a society just last week ccnc
canadian chinese national council
toronto
chapter launched the national wild
reporting
website to collect the data all kinds of
hatred instances during kobe 19.
the project is actually sponsored by
heritage canada digital program so thank
you for that
ccnc is also calling for reform of
justice
uh system for example setting up a
special task force
for the hate crime so my question is
other than this project is there any
other measures that
heritage canada or other federal
departments
is planning to do to address the issue
and so i think what's clear is that we
need ideas
and it's great that you're referring to
the program this is a
program that we brought out in response
to
a lot of the misinformation
disinformation that is
uh spreading unfortunately across our
country
so the digital citizen initiative is
actually to work with national
organizations
that work with local organizations to
actually counter that misinformation
and share real information and the facts
because we need to make our decisions
based
on evidence and science so yes that is
an initiative yes there are
other programs there are community
support multicultural programs as well
as anti-racism programs
and the applications are usually ongoing
and we will be doing more but we really
want to hear from community as to what
will work
oftentimes governments believe that they
have the answers
and we as the elected officials we can
definitely
lead the way and make investments but we
need to ensure that we're responding to
what community is asking for
so when it came to this work and the
need to collect that data
that was a proposal that was shared with
us that we were able to respond
to when it comes to reporting hate
crimes
we have to understand that it takes a
lot of courage
to report and to be able to say i was
targeted or this is an experience i went
through
because then people are also having to
relive that experience
but it's important that we collect this
data and we'd be aware
of what's taking place across our
country and that there's mechanisms in
place
to ensure that justice is served and
we're seeing that
currently with what's taking place uh
with the black lives matter movement and
the
marches and protests saying that it's
important
that our voices be heard and it's
important that our systems
work for every individual because canada
is diverse
and because we occupy so many
backgrounds and so much diversity
we need a system that actually does not
only reflect that but responds
and is held to account
yeah just uh i think this the racism
is not a new issue now you just
mentioned that we're watching the
protesters around
the world especially in united states
yesterday prime minister justin trudeau
just said
we watch it in horror so
in canada actually some politicians also
give a comment based on racial basis
so what's your comment on on those
issues
so i'll tell you i'm an asian canadian
myself my
parents immigrated from india in the
early 70s
and i'm born and raised in the waterloo
region
and i i'm definitely watching what's
happening in the world and i definitely
do think globally but i act locally and
i know that in canada we have a lot of
work to do
and that's where my focus is lying it's
lying within my community
within our country so that canada can
truly be that inclusive canada that
everyone talks about
um and i'm really proud of our
reputation and i'm really proud that
people see us as such an inclusive
society
but what's also evident is that
not all people feel safe within all
spaces of our country
and there are um acts of racism and acts
of violence taking place and that's what
i believe as a government we need to
respond to
i believe leaders respond and what we
can do
is make sure that mechanisms are in
place and that we are aware
that in canada racism does exist
anti-black
racism anti-asian racism exists
and we need to ensure that we're not
only listening
but that we are hearing the lived
experiences
taking them seriously and then being
able to work together
to find a more inclusive and better and
stronger
way forward so another generation
hopefully doesn't have to go through
this that's true
talking about a personal story
immigrant background a personal level
have you
have you yourself ever experienced
any kind of discrimination because you
are visible minority
and a woman i am
i'll tell you growing up in a community
like waterloo i'm really
proud and blessed to be um in this
community many people took me
under their wing and that's why i come
from a time where communities raise
children and i had amazing teachers
and i have amazing mentors and i have an
amazing family but yes
whether it is the color of my skin
whether it was the fact that i am
a woman and continue to look like a
young woman
um my name bartish is not a very common
name so there has been many facets of
which
i have definitely faced discrimination
and faced
um acts of racism and violence
um and i for me and i think the way our
community has been raised is that you
know
let's open our doors and share so the
more we were able to share about our
culture
and our religion and ourselves as people
the more we were able to build bridges
and with the community i think at some
point though it's not
just for the immigrant populations and
the diverse populations to be sharing
about themselves
i think safe spaces require
every individual to be part of that
conversation
um so as and i think every individual
can do better and so we really need to
reflect upon the spaces we occupy as
individuals as organizations as
government
and really look at who's not being
represented how do we have those voices
represented
and that's why i'm really pleased to be
within this role because when as a
federal government we are making
decisions
even though i personally do not have all
of the lived experiences
i do have mechanisms in place to be able
to reach out
to other communities and hear from them
and then represent those voices
and i am going to continue fighting to
not only represent those voices but to
have more of those voices present
at the decision-making table and i think
that's why it's important
that the the the appointments process
um continue to be strengthened and more
people
from different communities actually
apply and put their names forward so
that they can be considered
and then we can actually see if you know
the system is working and considering a
diversity of views and backgrounds and
perspectives or does that system need to
be changed and it is a new system
um so i really hope that more people put
themselves forward for the opportunities
so that the decision-making tables and
the policies we're coming out with
actually work for more canadians i
really do think about the generation
that comes
after us and i really do hope that they
have
less of these experiences and my dream
and my vision will always be that they
have none of these experiences
um but i do know that we have a lot of
work to do and
online we have seen a lot of
horrific comments horrid comments of
people
you know dismissing people's lived
experiences that
is not part of the solution that is part
of the problem but it does
remind us that racism
is not only in your face but racism is
also
hidden there is stealth racism and
not people's true selves don't always or
people's
you know biases and so forth don't
always shine until the opportunity comes
and we really do need to acknowledge and
respond to that
as well yeah my last question
uh anything you want to see to say
to asian community to minority community
regarding the potential racist threats
what do you want to see to them
any suggestions any advice
i would say that we are hearing a lot of
reports of anti-asian
racism of anti-chinese racism and
violent attacks
and i also know that you know
not all of it's been covered in the
media so please
know that i believe you
i know your experiences are true i know
they are difficult
my heart hurts to hear that this is what
you're experiencing
but we are committed to working together
to respond and to build an even more
inclusive
canada and that's exactly why um
the anti-racism secretariat is set up
and that's why we will put programs
forward and that's why
i'm pleased to hear that the digital
citizen initiative
is being used to counter some of these
points
you are not alone you have an ally and
you have
a partner uh in the government and i
want you to know that
we know the work that asian canadians
have
contributed to our great country may was
asian heritage month it was an
opportunity just
one another opportunity to celebrate the
contributions of asian canadians
but we can continue to celebrate year
long and
not only should we celebrate the
contributions and make more people aware
of the history of asian canadians in
canada
considering asian canadians have been in
canada before confederation
so been here a long time but we also do
need to come together to raise
the challenges and raise the realities
um
that exist and it takes a lot of courage
to do that
and i thank you for sharing um
those moments and i i'm sorry that you
have to relive them every time you share
them
but i do hope you know that this will
help us make sure another generation
does not have to
endure um acts of hate and violence and
racism we will get through this together
thank you thank you very much for uh
coming to my show to our program to talk
to us
thank you thank you so much for having
me well keep safe
everyone and i hope to see you again
thank you bye bye